les services de réanimation la crise
covid les a bien malgré eux propulsé en
pleine lumière et ce documentaire tourné
à l'hôpital de La Fontaine de
Saint-Denis en région parisienne vient
donc de nous permettre de mieux
comprendre leur utilité leur
fonctionnement pour la prise en charge
de malade de se trouvant le plus souvent
entre la vie et la mort son auteur est
maintenant avec nous sur ce plateau de
débat doc bienvenue
Eric Guéret vous êtes donc celui qui a
réalisé ce documentaire pronostic vital
vous êtes d'ailleurs spécialisé comme
c'est le cas ici d'ailleurs dans vos
films par un travail de très longue
période en totale immersion avec les
personnages les lieux que vous avez
décidé de mettre vous aussi en lumière
quelles sont les règles de tournage que
vous vous imposez lorsqu'il s'agit
justement de vous immerger dans un lieu
dans un sujet
moi je filme des combats et je filme en
général des combats intimes c'est-à-dire
des combats de personnes qui qui se
battent pour eux-mêmes mais dont le
combat individuel représente des combats
collectifs donc je suis obligé d'être
très proche de mes personnages alors
pour ça la première chose c'est d'être
tout seul c'est-à-dire que moi je suis
complètement autonome je fais l'image le
son je pose les questions et donc ça me
permet d'être vraiment au contact de au
plus proche de d'être au cœur de
l'intime et puis je filme pendant de
très longues périodes là c'était six
mois parfois j'ai filmé jusqu'à un an et
demi c'est à dire que je me mets pas de
limite dans la durée des films quoi
voilà ça c'est un peu les règles qui
permettent finalement de disparaître en
étant très présent et je suis pas je
suis pas petit j'ai une grosse caméra
mais voilà ce dispositif
d'une certaine manière je me fous dans
le décor c'est j'ai la place du collègue
dit aux gens vous pouvez me parler voilà
donc je suis tout le temps là tout le
temps avec eux et finalement et ben les
gens voyez ils font pas semblant que je
ne sois pas là mais il me parle il me
pousse il m'avait dit moi je discute
avec eux donc j'ai des confidences donc
dans ma position de cinéaste en fait
j'ai la position de celui avec qui on
travaille du collègue de travail il faut
demander des autorisations de tournage
j'imagine que en amont de ce tournage il
était facile de les obtenir et vous les
avez obtenus auprès de la direction de
cet hôpital de Saint-Denis en revanche
pour ce qui est de l'autorisation de
tournage du patients qui arrive dans ce
fameux service de réanimation les choses
de ne pas être aussi simple que cela
enfin j'avais très peu de temps pour
leur demander l'autorisation mais j'ai
obtenu l'autorisation toujours et ce que
je faisais c'est qu'en fait bon je
demandais l'autorisation avec un médecin
et puis après la première séquence et
quand je l'ai filmé plusieurs fois
chaque jour je leur reposais la question
est-ce que ça vous a pas dérangé est-ce
que vous êtes toujours d'accord donc je
faisais quand même attention que le
consentement soit éclairé le plus
éclairé possible et puis après je
demandais je posais la question à la
famille aussi alors d'autres c'est vrai
dans l'imaginaire collectif on s'attend
à l'urgence beaucoup de stress de cris
voir des larmes dans un service de
réanimation or ici ce qui frappe c'est
c'est le calme qui prévaut dans votre
film ou si tu la vérité alors en réalité
la vérité elle est là plus que dans les
films urgences tournés aux États-Unis
enfin dans les services de réanimation
français quand vous rentrez dans un
service de réa ce qui est d'abord
surprenant c'est le silence total tout
est très calme c'est des services qui
sont petits le personnel et très
méticuleux très affairé très
professionnel il y a pas un bruit il y a
deux moments où tout d'un coup tout
s'excite c'est quand un patient arrive
et là il y en a dans le film tout d'un
coup il y a 5 6 personnes autour parce
qu'il faut faire très vite le brancher
et puis quand il y a une urgence vitale
ou quand quelqu'un décroche ou quand
quelqu'un décède voilà là tout d'un coup
le service se met en effervescence mais
le reste du temps c'est extrêmement
calme extrêmement silencieux extrêmement
posé on peut pas traiter l'urgence dans
la confusion et donc voilà c'est c'est
maîtrisé quelle est la séquence qui vous
a le plus marqué à l'occasion de ce
tournage c'est difficile de choisir
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup mais c'est
vrai que moi j'ai toujours été touché
par les excumbations c'est à dire que
vous avez un patient qui arrive on lui
dit bon ben voilà il y a un problème on
va vous incuber ça va vous aider le
moment où on incube la personne on ne
lui dit pas réellement mais on n'est
jamais sûr qu'elle se réveille
et ça je pense que ça se sent à
l'extubation c'est à dire qu'à chaque
fois on a l'impression d'une naissance
il y en a dans le film qui sont montrés
les gens ont l'impression de renaître
ils remercient tout de suite disent
merci merci merci
est-ce que vous pouvez appeler mon mari
est-ce que vous pouvez appeler ma femme
et moi je suis bouleversé rien que de me
les rappeler c'est vrai que c'est le
moment où on touche du doigt en fait la
puissance de cette médecine de cette
belle médecine française quand même et
sa capacité à sauver des vies alors
c'est vrai que dans un service de
réanimation il y a une personne sur cinq
qui n'en sort pas mais il y en a quatre
quand même sur 5 qui en sorte et qui en
sorte grâce à ce professionnalisme et de
voir quelqu'un se réveiller être exubé
re respirer et remercier moi je trouve
que voilà c'est un magnifique hommage au
travail incroyable que font ces équipes
soignantes sachant qu'il y a une très
longue période de rééducation et de
réadaptation lorsqu'on sort d'un service
de réanimation alors on voit pas dans
vos films parce que oui mais c'est pas
gagné une fois qu'on est sorti en fait
quand on est intubé ce qu'on sait pas
c'est que l'incubation est le fait
d'être rallongé surtout quand les gens
sont endormis ventilés mécaniquement
donc par une machine qui les fait
respirer et intubé en fait très
rapidement les muscles fonde le corps
voilà perd de sa puissance et au bout de
une semaine de semaine quand il se
réveille les gens ne peuvent plus tenir
debout donc un mois de service de
réanimation un mois par exemple
d'incubation c'est énorme et j'ai filmé
des personnes qui sont dans ce film pour
nos patient parfois plusieurs mois et
ils ont fait trois ou quatre mois de
rééducation derrière pour réapprendre
quand mes bébés on envoie un on le voit
c'est une séquence que j'ai pas gardé
pardon mais il y en a il réapprend à
manger un yaourt à servir de ses mains à
se mettre debout à marcher faut tout
réapprendre alors vous avez qu'une
séquence que vous avez pas gardé y
a-t-il des séquences que vous êtes
interdit de filmer ou justement que vous
n'avez pas gardé lorsqu'il assèche une
de monter ce film il y a des séquences
que j'ai pas pu filmer parce que j'ai
pas eu l'autorisation de les filmer même
j'ai envie de dire que c'est presque
miraculé que j'ai pu en filmer autant
parce que c'est des gens très fragiles à
qui j'ai demandé de pouvoir les montrer
dans cet état là et c'était souvent
difficile mais après non je me suis
interdit je me suis rien interdit
globalement et en même temps en montage
je passe mon temps à m'interdire de
monter certaines parties des séquences
c'est à dire que je fais quand on filme
au cœur de l'intime il faut faire
attention de pas franchir la limite du
voyeurisme de la vulgarité et de rester
à la bonne donc c'est la pudeur qui doit
primer il faut de la pudeur d'ailleurs
les films sont forts quand ils sont
pudiques moi je j'évite de faire des
zoom avant quand les gens souffrent
quand ils pleurent j'ai plutôt tendance
à faire des zoom arrière je pense qu'il
faut garder la distance même par respect
pour les gens qu'on filme et si
aujourd'hui j'arrive je continue à
pouvoir aller filmer
aussi souvent aussi proche des gens qui
sont dans des difficultés immenses c'est
parce que mes films précédents plaident
pour moi et que justement je crois que
j'ai réussi à jamais être un délicat
enfin je l'espère en tout cas ensuite tu
souvent entre la vie la mort dans ce
service les questions éthiques comme
celle d'éventuelles acharnement
thérapeutique vous ont-elles réellement
sembler central dans les discussions
alors entre soignants ou alors entre
soignants et patients et famille des
patients elles sont
omniprées elles sont au cœur de chaque
journée de chaque discussion de chaque
décision médicale c'est-à-dire que la
question éthique et l'essence même du
service de réanimation donc j'ai dit il
y a une personne sur cinq peut-être sur
six ça dépend des époques etc qui ne va
pas s'en sortir et pour une bonne partie
de ces personnes elle décèdent suite à
des arrêts de traitement qui ont été
décidés de consensus avec la famille et
avec le groupe de médecins donc je l'ai
filmé il y a des staffs qui s'appelle
des staffetic où toute l'équipe médicale
se retrouve toute l'équipe médicale
c'est du chef de service au médecin
infirmier aide-soignant de votre film
tout le monde est convoqué à s'exprimer
et à décider de savoir sur un cas précis
si on n'est pas dans l'acharnement
thérapeutique et s'il faut continuer à
traiter c'est des questions extrêmement
délicates et infiniment délicates et
voilà elles sont gérées heureusement
collectivement c'est des choix que
personne ne peut faire seul un arrêt de
traitement et gérer au coût par coup
gérer évidemment de l'état de chaque
patient deux minutes en minutes discuter
entre soignants les a bien vu dans votre
film discussion aussi entre soignants
et famille des patients oui oui très
difficile on arrête on n'arrête pas une
mort cérébrale mais malgré tout le corps
continuant encore à vivre tout ça est
très bien expliqué dans votre film là
aussi ce sont des moments de très forte
émotion dans ce film et que vous avez dû
vivre comme tel au moment du tournage
oui je les ai vécu qu'avec les familles
parce que la relation avec les familles
est extrêmement complexe c'est-à-dire
bon
tout le monde a peur il y a une douleur
immense de voir un de ses proches entre
la vie et la mort et donc la manière
dont s'adresse aux familles ce qu'on
leur dise qu'on leur dit pas la dose de
vérité qui sont prêts à entendre et
celles qui implicitement demande de ne
pas savoir c'est des jeux très
compliqués très très compliqué et là moi
je les ai trouvés remarquable alors
j'espère que je suis dans un service de
réanimation qui ressemble à tous et que
c'est fait partout comme ça mais en tout
cas moi ce que j'ai vu à l'hôpital de La
Fontaine c'est franchement une gestion
extrêmement fine de la relation avec la
famille de l'annonce des difficultés
du partage avec la famille de l'arrêt
des traitements de décider ou pas de la
mort de quelqu'un parce que de toute
manière ça terminera comme ça il faut
que la famille la comprenne de laisser
aussi aux familles le temps d'accepter
la disparition de son proche avant de
mettre fin en traitement il y a aussi
parfois des soins de confort qui sont un
peu prolongés pour laisser aux familles
le temps donc voilà c'est très bien fait
la question des dons d'organes est
également abordé dans votre documentaire
elle est importante cette question au
sein de ce service j'en ai pas vu
énormément c'est pas des cas hyper
fréquents mais en réanimation évidemment
il y a des personnes qui arrivent et
quand elles arrivent qui peuvent être en
mort cérébrale
la grande difficulté c'est de faire
accepter à la famille que leurs proches
qui voit qui respire grâce à une machine
dont le cœur bat grâce à des médicaments
en fait est décédé alors qu'elle est
vivante c'est extrêmement compliqué et
là on leur demande dans un temps très
court parce qu'il faut aller très vite
de se prononcer sur la possibilité du
don d'organe alors en France la loi est
très claire si vous n'avez pas refusé le
don d'organe et si vous n'êtes pas
inscrit sur la liste des refus ça veut
dire que vous êtes d'accord donc on
pourrait il pourrait les équipes
soignantes pourraient se passer de
l'accord de la famille mais dans les
fêtes ils ne le font pas globalement pas
parce que voilà par délicatesse
justement par rapport à l'accompagnement
des familles dont je parlais tout à
l'heure il pose la question savoir si le
proche dans sa vie s'est exprimé en
faveur ou en défaveur du don d'organes
et en fonction de ça donc il y a une
décision collégiale de le faire c'est
évidemment des tragique mais là encore
quelle incroyable prouesse de la
médecine de se dire que quelqu'un qui
est décédé peut aider d'autres personnes
à survivre à voir avoir des coeurs un
cœur qui bat voire des poumons qui
respirent ailleurs voilà il faut
évidemment que ce soit
accompagné par une démarche
humaine voilà très puissante mais voilà
c'est incroyable les services de
réanimation et leurs difficultés c'est
vrai ont été mis en lumière lors de la
crise de la covid les séquelles de cette
crise sanitaire était-il perceptible
lors du tournage auprès du personnel
soignant sachant que vous avez tourné
durant la seconde la deuxième et la
troisième bague oui oui mais après j'ai
mis longtemps à monter le film donc en
fait je puis je suis resté en contact
il y a des séquelles
l'hôpital va pas bien c'est pas une
nouvelle mais il allait pas bien avant
la crise de la covid et puis vous
rappelez-vous il y a eu une année de
grève avant avec des revendications qui
sont arrêtées pendant la crise de la
covid et ça ça s'est terminé avec le
Ségur de la santé ou ce gouvernement a
dit qu'il avait réglé les problèmes de
l'hôpital en prenant des grandes
décisions et ça ça a été extrêmement mal
vécu par les équipes
submergé à l'occasion de la première
vague de communauté
ils ont mis leur revendications de côté
et surtout pour les personnels
paramédicaux ils ont tout donné et ils
ont été extrêmement mal remerciés et ce
qui s'est passé la séquelles la plus
importante pour l'hôpital c'est que
depuis le personnel est parti c'est à
dire qu'il y a une partie des lits
d'hôpitaux qui sont fermées parce qu'il
y a plus d'infirmiers il y a plus
d'aide-soignants pour les faire tourner
c'est à dire que on a tellement bien
remercié le personnel soignant d'avoir
sauvé autant de vie pendant les crises
de la covid que ces héros d'un jour ont
été oubliés le lendemain et aujourd'hui
ont quitté pour partie l'hôpital et
l'hôpital n'arrive plus à fonctionner
donc il est grand temps moi franchement
c'est une banalité que de le dire
tellement tout le monde le dit mais
c'est quand même bien de le rappeler il
est grand temps de considérer le
personnel soignant comme il doit l'être
de le payer correctement pour qu'il
continue à faire tourner l'hôpital
public parce que sans lui il y aura pas
d'hôpital public possible et aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le cas en tout cas nous
avons un quota de résistance confie une
infirmière dans votre film est-ce que
vous l'avez touché de près ce quota de
résistance au côté des soignants et à
quelle occasion bah oui en fait
l'infirmière qui prononce cette phrase
dans le film a quitté l'hôpital depuis
malheureusement ce que malheureusement
ce qu'elle est vraiment formidable oui
l'espérance de vie d'une infirmière
avant c'était trois ans rien de bien sûr
aujourd'hui c'est moins en évolanteur
lorsqu'on on est infirmières on est un
soignant dans un service de réanimation
on est volontaire aide-soignant dans un
service de réanimation c'est forcément
du volontariat c'est extrêmement
engageant déjà c'est hyper technique
hyper pointu techniquement et puis c'est
extrêmement engageant humainement
moralement on est confronté à la mort
très souvent plus souvent qu'on en a
envie parfois avec des femmes enceintes
voilà parfois avec des gens qui sont
jeunes donc oui il y a de l'usure on
nous demande mentale on la ramène
ensuite à son domicile on l'a évidemment
phrase très belle dans le film elle dit
tant qu'on a nos blues ça va l'INO blues
c'est nos costumes de super héroïne et
on essaye de laisser les problèmes avec
la blouse dans le vestiaire mais c'est
rarement ce qui se passe et évidemment
les problèmes ils peuvent rentrer à la
maison ils peuvent fatiguer ils peuvent
épuiser et oui il y a des il y a des il
y a du personnel qui tient pas et on ne
peut pas leur en vouloir ils ont donné
tout ce qui donc c'est infirmière qui
témoigne depuis quitter le service ce
turn over du service par épuisement
suite à cette fameuse charge mentale
justement vous l'avez vu aussi vous
l'avez observé vous avez eu changé le
personnage durant toute cette durée de
tournage moi j'ai vu des gens partir
pendant le tournage voilà j'ai vu des
gens qui sont arrivés très très motivés
et puis il y a force voilà qui ont
besoin de de passer un peu le relais
mais c'est pas critiquable c'est juste
que c'est un marathon c'est un marathon
avec la vie et avec la mort au quotidien
tous les jours et que voilà en plus
comme je l'ai dit comme on est en plus
pas très bien remercier par l'État et
par les hôpitaux du travail qu'on donne
qu'on fournit pardon ben ouais ça peut
ça peut participer de l'épuisement une
manière de tenir c'est la solidarité
entre personnel aide-soignant c'est ce
qui est aussi ce qui ressort de votre
film la solidarité l'engagement c'est à
dire que franchement
ce métier de personnel soignant repose
sur l'engagement et l'ensemble de
l'hôpital public repose sur l'engagement
de ce personnel s'il y avait pas cet
engagement on gagne mieux sa vie dans le
privé pour venir travailler là dans le
public c'est qu'on a envie de donner de
soi aux autres merci
Eric merci pour ce film ce formidable
documentaire pronostic vital que nous
avions le plaisir de présenter dans
cette émission d'evadoc vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter
merci aussi à sel massalik qui m'a aidé
comme à l'accoutumée à préparer cette
émission je vous donne tout simplement
prendre rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera bien entendu avec
son documentaire et son débat à très
bientôt
[Musique]